okay Star Trek fans you know what this
is this is the health tricorder that
measures your vital signs from the
original sci-fi series of the 1960s 49
years ago this black box was science
fiction but today this little white
wonder is science facts this is the
scanadu scout and it measures your vital
signs at the touch of your forehead
walter de Brouwer is SCANA news
co-founder and CEO based at NASA's Ames
Research Park in Silicon Valley show me
how it works yeah so you just click the
app it says let's get scanning mm-hmm
put your finger here put it now on your
head
Walter asked to keep his vital secret
but I was fine with sharing mine blood
pressure is good Oh 112 over 63 my heart
rates is that normal yeah I'll 40-48
screaming right I run pretty much every
day joking aside Walter says this kind
of self-awareness can lead to course
corrections for healthier lives like for
Patrick Schulich one of 8,000 beta
testers he discovered a problem I found
that I actually have a trend of high
blood pressure I realized it's something
that's happening to me every day it's
high and I've actually taken action got
it checked out and on a treatment plan
for it the Scout is in the process of
FDA trials further down the road
personal liquids are a newer focus
Walter's wife Sam heads up scan a new
urine which tests for 12 different
problems and diabetes to the presence of
blood and protein today I'm the guinea
pig
I'll spare you some of the details but
the process involves a paddle with test
squares and and in about a minute my
results so clear is good it's very good
I could sleep well it's a night knowing
that thank you and that knowledge of
self is coming as we build our health
history day by day before you know it in
a year you have made a thousand little
decisions and these mount do something
very big readings indicate a life form
in the vicinity apparently human Star
Trek tricorder debuted in the 23rd
century your very own is about two
hundred years ahead of schedule